[Music]
more Tartu more Kody and a booty lurking
[Music]
now that the award-winning redzone
recovery plan has been signed off by
government we can begin the work what
was formerly known as red zone is now an
area of regeneration the consultation
that has taken place is being widely
acclaimed winning the supreme awards at
both the New Zealand Planning Institute
Awards and the local government
management Awards design work for the
roading recreational facilities in green
space is featured in the plan are the
key priorities the waterfront is already
looking amazing and our community will
continue to drive the process and
partnership with the council through
every stage of the development
[Music]
this month we're looking at the timeline
for completion of the various projects
within the regeneration areas the job is
massive covering five areas over 100
hectares combined most of the work is
expected to be finished in the next two
to ten years the first vector began will
be the roading and we've been receiving
feedback from our community about the
roading designs for Courtney Drive and
the new rating link between fabric drive
race Ridge Street and Cass Street we
controlled it with the community
recently on the design for the rebuild
of Courtney Drive and hopefully we'll
have contractors on site in July and
with the recall finished by the end of
the year in 2018 design work for the
sports fields will be underway and
construction of the Riverview terraces
will be progressing work will begin on
the new roading link and Kai point east
regeneration area and we should see the
first sod being tuned for the BMX track
and dog park the planning and design of
the new reserve impact is well underway
and we're working on some really
exciting features we're looking forward
to sharing these ideas with the
community over the coming month also
planned for this area our food forest
and walking and cycling track these are
all activities that our community told
us they wanted during the development of
the draft recovery plan land is also
being set aside for a motor home and
caravan park and for exciting new retail
and business options for the cowboy town
center so this is an exciting time for
Carrefour and we want you to be a part
of it the carpet or here we community
board will be holding fortnightly
drop-in sessions here at the library and
the rural town of our Civic Center and
we'd like you to come in and talk to us
next month we'll be looking at the
design for the river view terraces on
the north side of the Copper River and
talk to local developer jib Pierre will
meet Landscape Architect Kevin Dwyer and
check in on what progress has been made
along the ky4 river water thing for more
information about the regeneration visit
any council service center or
Waimakariri dot govt tnz ford slash
regeneration
[Music]